大家好
今天台灣股市看起來大漲千點了
結果再次崩盤
台灣股市最後居然殺下去了
我的10050馬上賺錢嗎
哇今天很多人在算
我到底賺幾百萬
結果到最後又殺下去了
我還有賺錢嗎
等一下算給你看
第二個
肺的利率不變
那下次是不是要升息了
9月是不是確定要升息
那9月台股市要封定了
哇不會
風火連三月吧
崩到9月太恐怖了吧
第三個
微軟大坎資本支出
老AI沒救了嗎
今天管他為何跌停板
這些老AI是不是通通沒救
怎麼辦
我的手錶什麼時候可以輸回
怎麼辦 這開玩笑的
不過今天很多股票跌得莫名其妙
我真的很氣 我好想買啊
等一下我要告訴你更多標股
台股真的瘋啦
早盤一度大漲千點
結果最後又殺下去
最後小跌105點
收在39933點
投资长昨天大手笔砸了一亿新台币
进场大买0050
结果今天台股早盘马上反弹向上
一度大涨超过千点
很多人在帮投资长数是不是赚了好几百万
结果最后跌下去又再算赔了几百万呢
投资长怎么办
而虽然台股早盘一度大涨
投资朋友的心情还是七上八下的
尤其今天环球金和国具又打到跌停
到底为什么会这样呢?
投资朋友都很紧张
分不清楚究竟应该是要绝命大逃杀
还是这是无敌买点呢?
对于微软降低资本支出
投资长又是怎么看的呢?
接下来就交给我们经济日报选股冠军
单季188%的记录保持者
同时也是全台湾唯一百万粉丝
最受欢迎的分析师
是國哲榮投資長
投資長好
Lily
各位投票大家好
恭喜今天
幾十萬的觀眾
願意看我
喔 回來啊 回來啊
135萬的粉絲
跌率有時候
都來個十幾萬而已
哇 現在幾十萬觀眾在看我啦
是
哇嗨啊
我看到的是幾位
你們看到什麼
今天喔
早晨一拉起來
喔這個跟瘋子一樣
PTT啊 翠啊
我馬上多了好多藍粉絲女粉絲你知道嗎
超排一拉的時候 喔 極拉占千點啦
從39404點啦
拉到41105點
喔 不止喔 這樣低到高1760
有沒有看錯啊
欸對
是喔 我都鎖錯啊
1000多點啦
低到高1000多點啦
喔 好扯喔
這人每個人在算啊
哲哲你郭哲隆買一億
郭哲隆是神
相信哲哲增加層層
哲哲好厲害啊
說說是很厲害
酸人說
郭哲隆
你買了一億又怎麼樣
你會有現在在彈雪啊
環球機在疊提音盤啊
我跟你說
那時候我很不開心
因為如果今天我不是分析師
我今天一定
錢靠下去
買環球機
我跟你講啊
我給你一個簡單理論就好了
我覺得很多股票是這樣
國劇也殺過頭了
今天又在各地街廳班
國劇有進產啦
不要再說我罵00981A啦好不好
好不好
我現在跟00981A的那個姚慈欽姆
我姚慈欽姆之前有的人說我罵他
沒有
我支持你
我跟你講
我說甚至你現在可以買00981A
如果你不知道什麼時候要買
什麼要買
我做人很公道啦
我做人不拗人家
你打聽我郭忠為人啦
我告訴大家做生意我很公道
我告訴你這個股票現在就是可以買
國際的可以買
可是我也懇求主管機關
證交所 真的
因為我不是分析師 我不要太慫
手動人家
把那個儲置改一改
像一堆股票被儲置
你懂不懂
是
你下跌的時候 你反正儲置要打開
不是下跌還被儲置
股票最怕是流動性問題
你儲置是人家追漲停 讓人家清醒一點
下跌你還儲置 20 分鐘交易是誰要買
這制度真的吃了好改
好我也不多說了
我只要告訴你一件事情
今天早盤漲上去的時候
大家說我在賺錢
然後我賺了好幾百萬
我很不開心
因為
我有股票跌停
尾盤我台灣50殺下去了
我沒什麼賺錢
我滿開心
為什麼
因為我希望你們通通踏著我的雪前進
這我的名言
踏著我的雪前進
All in
應該知道All in什麼
現金壓好壓滿
你們會愛我
我再給你們一個信息你們看
我都有新聞
我跟你講
哲哲這一次很紅
我先不講這一次
去年我買了這邊
你們不要懷疑
就買了這邊
2024年
去年買
錢你買了這邊對不對
對不對
厲害
現在就完崩盤也有4萬點左右
去年你跟著我
你什麼都不要動
像我說的長期投資
你18000你至少賺一倍
你賺1000萬賺到2000萬
你賺2000萬賺到至少4000萬
你知道嗎
去年跟著我崩盤的時候直接買進
談不是2200點是22000點
你會愛死我國中
我懇求你們
再給自己最後一次愛哲哲的機會
現在買
All in 現金
All in
全押我知道你還有錢
把你褲膽裡面的錢
把你在抽屜裡面的錢
小時候你有錢
租公 租宅
全部宰出來
知道嗎
不然你會恨你自己
會恨你自己
到時候你最討厭看的是
郭忠的重播
你看到這邊買喔
2020年11月11號
你不相信對不對
那時候崩盤是崩盤個5000點有沒有知道
有
等同現在崩盤1萬點
比這次還長
那時候買來看
我先重播
重播成播來看一下
我今天很嗨喔
今天節目很精彩
2025年
對 2025年
4月11月12
有沒有看到
2025年4月11月12
沒錯吧
是不是相對最低點
是
18000耶
看清楚喔
2025年4月11號
我買台灣50
去打聽一下我郭總買台灣50
我公開操作基本上百發百中
姊姊 你要買美債
我先討論是台灣50
而且我美債
我至少講過100次了
美債留給我賠錢
我美債第一次賺1000多萬喔
依依沒錯吧
沒錯
我去台灣賺1000多萬
1500萬
我第一次賺錢
第二次我後悔了
我還不了解美債這東西
但台灣50
我真的比誰都了解
我還叫你美債換台灣50
如果美債換台灣50
基本上都賺一倍以上
你第一時間聽到我講的話
所以不要怪我美債
基本上我公開操作
尤其台灣50
過去的機率是100%
都是平均賺1000萬以上
你看我4月10號
2015年4月10號
你別忘記了對不對
看重播
去年重播
我影片網路上都可以找到
我今天怎樣
買了6000萬0050有沒有看到
有
台灣50
剛好買的低點拉起來了
很多人問我說
你之前不是有一堆美債嗎
你是把美債出新的
換台灣50嗎
是這樣子嗎
還是你這是台灣50
是誰用現金買
還是用借錢的
應該要借錢買股
我還討論這東西
跟現在一樣
表不見了
這則是不是抵押了
你是不是抵押美債
我一律不建議你去用借錢
因為我不知道你的情況
可是如果你要借
那你就要買最
風險最低的
比如說你就買貪物
借錢就不要去買股票了
然後比如說你資產
你資產有1000萬
你房貸有
假設你有5000萬的房貸
有底線型房貸
那你去買個500萬1000萬
我覺得還可以接受
而且你可能是有穩定的現金
你有工程師啊醫生啊
你本身心存用很高
你這些貸款的資金20%以下
我覺得或許可以考慮
或許而已
我講是很極端條件
可是我最好就全部都是現金 all in
2025年8月11日有沒有看到
你看我每次都充滿了自信
很多人說這次就算錯了我也充滿自信
不是
你們看現在是覺得我錯
看之後就覺得我來自未來
2025年有沒有看到
崩盤的
2024年更誇張
從24000有沒有看到
一路崩崩到19000也是崩個5000點有沒有
有
跟現在很像
等於現在的崩1萬點
是
有沒有看到
唐為進2萬4千點也是一樣
1萬9
這去年跟前年
這個買得更漂亮
買這一根
你看這一根也跟現在很像
有沒有
上下去以後隔天還在破底
可是今天很像
是
還在洗盤
同學我告訴你
今天這種跌法
中小型個股跌法已經是金融海消等級了
我還是希望主管機關喊個話
流動性問題 處置問題
喊個話
台灣股市就會救出來了
我告訴大家好不好 喊個話
不要只是嘖嘖一個人
彈籃膽居
來
什麼叫彈籃膽居
看一下
我很辛苦但我很開心
來看一下
彈籃膽居有沒有看到
彈籃有沒有看到
彈籃知道這彈籃有沒有
彈籃有沒有到
有
貪婪膽區
這是什麼意思 就是你小小一個貪婪 會看到
喔 要膽這個車 怎麼辦 不自量力
有沒有看到 台股崩盤
一翼大驚 則則一翼大驚 撐住台股 有沒有看到
台股崩盤
郭子宏代理一翼大驚 撐住台股
貪婪膽區 永不退縮
这个
这个为什么这个展局啊
为什么这个展局啊
没有啊就是发音不正确嘛
是不是
好不好
这里有没有看到有叙叙有没有看到
有耶
张宁鹿演什么
竹谕在什么
那叫什么
什么什么
武安侯
现在我也跟大家说武安啦
古有张宁鹿演武安侯
在竹谕
现在有
有這則
演壇男膽居在台股
我一大天撐得住台股嗎
撐不住我也沒有一定要撐
你們太把我想太厲害了
可是我不在乎
因為到最後我是對的就好了
我管你我是壇男
還跳著
我贏就好了
撐得住就好了
你們記得來
團結
信心
紀律
策略
勝利
有沒有看到
我們現在一起喊口號
好
我給大家信心
來
團結
信心
紀律
策略
勝利
依依妳不團結喔妳有沒有喊
有
再來一次
團結
信心
紀律
策略
SANNY
好啦 你們會覺得說
姊姊來鬧喔
喔 我不是來鬧
沒關係 撤退 謝謝
我不是來鬧
你說姊姊你搞像直銷大會
沒有 我故意的
我讓你記得一件事情
你現在就是要喊口號
你要麻醉你自己
你每天看台股真的不看
我現在也沒在看
看著心情不好
我待在辦公室
我稍微出去走走
我跟你講
我沒在看
幹嘛看
上APP也可以
可是你不能刪哲哲的節目
你上下去你看不下去啦
你會賣股票啦我也記得這些口號哇崩盤的時候還有人搞笑對我故意搞笑給你看崩盤的時候還有人願意雜儀
那你笑笑
我就這樣子
我很不喜歡你說我賺錢我或也沒賺錢
我真的聽得很難過
那我寧願不買
或者我自己偷偷買
不是 我反而喜歡今天我最後崩
我也要跌一起跌
可是我告訴你那是短暫的看我而已
長期以後你愛我
好多人傳給我你知道嗎
男生傳這個圖片給我
他們最喜歡圖片是什麼
就命一條
是
就命一條衝就對了
很多男生喜歡這個圖你知道嗎
女生傳給我
我就支撐你的心
沒有錯
你們遇到了風吹一打
來走走走
不然你渡不過這段時間
不論你是巴尼尼也好
你是大美女也好
或者是小美女也好
我來撐住你們
這則真的不是為了自己賺錢
我告訴你
台灣股市到5萬點
我再捐第三台救護車
5萬點
等一下我更正一下
6萬點好了
5萬點還賺2千多萬
你看這一台救護車現在漲價了
我最近有去問
再一台嗎
再一台6萬點
好不好
那6萬點吧
我1億賺6萬點
那時候大概
差不多賺五千萬吧
好不好 再一台 第三台
差不多明年到了啦 明年就會六萬點了啦
今年五萬點 明年六萬點啦
你相信我啦
你相信我講的話啦
我救護車每次都這樣過來的啦
不要再說我什麼賺不賺錢
我聽了我都不開心
我買這個東西喔
從頭到尾是點數啦
我是這樣帶空調的你知道嗎
是你自己要過來
老天爺要送錢給我花的
好不好
郭子翁大領一大軍撐出台股
喜歡圖片嗎
談談談軍
永不退縮
圖片不錯
比例有問題
思想幫我改一下比例
我感覺這個會是梗圖啊
來來來來
你們要記得一件事情
我賠錢沒有關係
我反而很開心
不要你們賠錢
就
就算
我買了一億再跟你講一次
就算我買一億虧大錢
壯烈犧牲
我還是愛你們
再講一次
就算我買一億虧大錢
壯烈犧牲
我還是愛你們
你們記得這句話就好
錢喔 你知道為什麼賺那麼多嗎
有時候你錢反正儲資太難
ok
我再跟你講個東西啊
你知道為什麼買股票是個風險比較低
我講相對而言我是賺大錢
來喔
我今天看到新聞我看得很生氣
你知道熊本最近不是有那個嗎
地震
地震嗎
地震不是應該旅遊不變險嗎對不對
是
是不是
應該要賠嘛對不對
對
東升財經講的啦有沒有看到
台灣旅客
取消九州行啊
旅遊平安險跟不變險不理賠啦
為什麼
因為交通部並會針對對熊本發布
禁止旅遊的警示
蛤
所以這樣就賠不到了
你每天搞文字遊戲幹什麼
我就是不懂
有些人就說哇我疫情
我不是在丟你們
那些都是小錢
你買小錢你賺不了大錢
什麼意思
你這些東西那是小確信
你們記得一件事
我不知道丟很多人
我講事實
小確信永遠讓你賺不了大錢
我排隊
我排雞排
免費的
我不是丟你們
可是這是事實
我排雞排OK可以小確信
可是你要告訴自己
小確幸賺不太大錢
大危機可以讓你賺大錢
我問你啊
你們每天我受險我買的小確幸
哇除非你就是我真的
比如說你家裡真的
我要養家人我要養小孩什麼
你不能倒那你就買個受險
哇你甚至連醫療險你要知道
他等我們針對你的證據
你不知道你哪有時間去解讀這東西啊
不要說啊你不要時間解讀啊
可是現在你知道我在解讀
我在解讀那些因為我每天都要簽名
你知道嗎
我說叫Gemmine
叫公司的總監先看一遍
我叫Gemmine再看一次
哇有時候他比律師還清楚
律師沒有那麼細心
這跟夏威奇為什麼
為什麼AlphaGo
夏威奇過後
贏了那個韓國騎完以後
為什麼從此以後再贏不了
最近有一個韓國
是韓國還是中國的騎王
贏了我發現
浪良子
你以為夏威奇知道浪良子差多少
扯遠了
我意思是說其實那就是代表AI可以一直無遠伏借
幫你當法律助理很多助理
醫學助理醫學教授扯遠的
你知道為什麼我跳到這新聞很討厭
我就說我不是要去
我不要貶低從業人員
我覺得受險是要買
你有些錢要發存款
可是你要發很少在這些上面
為什麼
記得這句話
你記得這句話你懂嗎
銀行賺什麼錢
賺你存款的利差
什麼意思
我訂存給你2%
我借人家
我去買投資股票
我賺20%
你買1000萬
你賣1000萬
我一年賺你180萬
沒錯吧 天啊
銀行幫你賺什麼錢
是
我說事實
我沒有
我不是要批評那些從業人員啊
我講的是事實
這是銀行的機制
你賣錢越來銀行越多
你幫人家數鈔票
你一輩子成不了大富翁
你看起來我1000萬
我有20萬利息
這壞掉了
真的壞掉了
你那換機通貨嘛
你永遠賺不了大錢
把錢全部放在銀行最傻
所以密一條你就放在股市嘛
不懂
我講我現在血管快爆漏了
我激動
密一條
不要擔心
每天都會去運動
我就覺得我很激動
密一條
放在股市嘛
人生苦轉了
你不拚一下什麼錢
一年就有時候這一次的機會
台股之餐這種跌法已經是
真的是金融海峽等級了
中小雲各股有點誇張 真的有點誇張
這個比去年前年還誇張
去年前年國際沒有這種崩盤
你懂嗎
沒有這種崩盤
政府真的要稍微沒有這種崩盤
今天又可以殺下去
這太誇張了啦
就算明後天連續兩個展停板我也覺得很正常
沒有這種崩盤的1220到456
你打三折那種跌法
全值股
你夠六四八八環球金我氣死了
神經喔
EBS怎麼付的
人家是用
人家是子公司股價的
股價影響他的一個
影響他一個什麼金融損益啊
那個不是現金流
又不是真正的業內
你知道嗎
懂
我扯遠了
我要扯遠一次
來聽我講
聽我講這東西來
我好激動
你把錢放在銀行
銀行的設計是要賺你利差
你一輩子不才能大波
你把錢放在受險
我好確信
放在投資
投資金錢寶丹
你敢說
他永遠的設計就是要賺你這些寶丹的費用
是不是
如果你理賠了
全部人都理賠大於什麼
你全部設計是理賠
我全部理賠金啊
大於你受險公司的收入啊
就是保費收入啊
那不全部倒閉了
你懂嗎
是耶
所以受險 鐵頭資型保單這些東西
你全部的設計就是要賺的這些
就是要從你身上賺錢嘛
我也沒說完
你講這些保費就是從你身上賺錢嘛
只是有些人有些人賺得到
有些人賺不到你懂不懂
懂
保險公司銀行設計就是從你身上賺錢嘛
這是事實啊
我們要批評別人的啊
可是今天你買股票幹嘛
你買對股票幹嘛
台經驗員工幾萬名現在替你加班
我現在講話他們在加班 他們加班幹嘛
他們加班在幹嘛嘛
再增加EPS
增加EPS股價就會增加
所以股價中產期下降
股價中產期下降 你再記得一件事情
你買股票
就是成千上萬幾十萬幾百萬的員工在幫你加班
然後那股票設計呢 很簡單
上市會東市的董事 你要一定有持股啊
一定有持股啊
我有股票啊
我怎麼可能錢都分給員工
你懂不懂
懂
所以我的
而且也有人在監理啊
也有人在監察啊
也有監察人啊
所以我股票的設計是
我賺完錢以後
我分給員工分給一些管理費用以後
我要極大化我股東利益啊
所以股票是更好啊
我不能說銀行是更壞
但是其實他的設計
股票的設計
就是你在投資這家公司的時候
幾萬名的人
幾百萬
幾萬名台積電員工
幾十萬名的科技業的員工
無時無刻 包含現在講話的時候
他們還在拚命把你賺錢
就撐住
撐住好不好
真的撐住
真的撐住好不好
我開始有點激動 我現在稍微休息一下好累
好累喔 先看一下
看一下那留言
来休息一下好了
太累了
好嗨哦
太激动了
分支带头叫大家all in
不行吗
是不是
all in all in又不怎么样
可以all in
如果你觉得all in
我也可以分上同支哦
哎呀没有关系啦
好不好
我推荐保雅 融言
来
融资从最高点
经减肥1000多亿了
差不多
本来就差不多了
好不好
快撐不住 快撐不住了
你是現金有什麼撐不住
不要看他
看哲哲節目
這樣就好了好不好
好
看哲哲節目
哲哲開始給你算錢的時候
我賺多少錢的時候
你差不多你也賺錢了
好不好
OK
只在激動一下很好玩好不好
個股都要死絕了
我就說政府一定要做個作為
我真的覺得
因為這個已經
這個因為
不好意思
因為他們不能說
我不能怪他們
他們比較不敏感一點點
不像我那麼敏感
你怎麼每天
我是說我對股票很敏感
我們要形容我的什麼身體
或什麼好不好
不要誤會
官員們他沒有那麼敏感
這不能怪他們
可是現在中小型個股
是全值股的崩跌法
這個已經金融海嘯等級了
跌太快了
這個有點誇張
你要給信心
不是要說信心行話
不要再行股市信心行話
你改變個處置制度也好
或怎麼樣
或者直接說我政府就要護盤
你知道OK嗎
對這裡沒錢都要負盤
沒關係那就all in
為什麼 我問你一件事啦
再給你們 我在那邊打馬飛啦
台灣股市這樣崩
最後會上5萬點甚至上10萬點
我請問你最後會起來
會不會起來
會
會起來
你居然會起來
我管你是買這邊
我叫你買這邊啦
我管你是買這邊還是買這邊
之後都會賺錢 全對股票都會賺錢
你分散投資就會賺錢了
我叫你all in
沒有錯 我叫你all in
為什麼叫你all in單壓個股
你要搞清楚我的邏輯啊
為什麼all in
沒關係 你們居然批評我
那你現在有本事跟我對坐
你去喊空 坐空 去坐空
你現在又給我坐空
有本事我們真金白銀
我都已經講兩三次了
我每
不是兩次 我講幾百次了
每一次
我台灣50買的時候
都買的很漂亮
長期看都買的很漂亮
你找不到全臺灣比我更紅的分析師
你看我今天搜尋郭哲隆
很扯你知道嗎
你看一下
這邊搜尋郭哲隆找不到嗎
有
你看搜尋哲哲
為什麼搜尋哲哲
是要搜尋郭哲隆比較好
有沒有
郭哲隆招學習
郭哲隆真的雜一億買0050
郭哲隆雜一億買0050
校稱單手錶湊錢
Yahoo
郭總說到做到
Facebook
有沒有
TPPS老天爺送錢給我
TPPS好多現在記者要找來採訪
我說
我實在沒時間沒心情好不好好對兌現成交紀錄到現在還有人覺得是假的好不好哇 總統真的每一家新聞都在報導你們
金周刊
喔 這些只是某一則而已
是
金周刊的是
哇
0050點到93點幾元
今年台灣股市3.5萬點
我拜託你們
有時候我賠錢的時候
報導都很多
以後我賺錢的時候可以報導多一點吧
每次賠錢的喔
你們在想到我
點閱率也是一樣
好啦 我休息一下
要告訴你更多台股秘密啦
很多股票今天夢名其妙的崩盤跌停
你們精彩也是一樣
環境經營也是一樣
為什麼會這樣子
我那休息一下
跟你讓我休息一下我也好激動
那跟大家講更多台股機密
休息一下嗎回來
曹社長接下來還有哪些股市機密
要分享給大家呢
看一下
來來
來
人家有講
這個夜盤準備下課
折折耿毒就增加了
沒有關係
新會員稍微長一點
就位也轉了
就位也轉了 其實有算蠻多
只是也拖了不少啦
可是我告訴大家
我有點意思
如果到最後 我問大家一件事
我問大家一件事
我認為真的
我還是覺得環球金有機會兩千元
你記得我的話好不好
如果到最後環球金兩千元了
778你要謝謝我還是怪我
現在你一定都怪我
你們都看很轉
只會有那麼轉嗎
你不要汙汙汙好不好
我看東西有那麼轉嗎
我叫你all in就all in
叫你中壓就中壓
我沒跟你開玩笑了
欸 買一億
我壓力不是去湊錢那一億
壓力是多少人要看我笑話
可是我每一次都化銜為一
叫你all in就all in
不要跟我開玩笑
你以後謝謝我
你以後會愛我一輩子
我的粉絲都這樣增加了
每一次到最後
疊了的時候大家都看我笑話
最後我都看那些人看笑話
誰是笑話
别人看我太疯癫
我叫他人看不穿啊
看此节目我们觉得心情比较好
有啦
我今天告诉我我今天死命喔
就是让你们心情好一点
好不好
说还很口号喔
看有点傻啦
但是让大家开心一点 ok 吗
大声什么啦
我不大声你怎么会记得我
是不是
没那么短好不好
再来一亿卖啦
再来一亿真的要凑钱的啦
我發現我老闆在看哲哲
聰明都喜歡看我好不好
節目
我認我的邏輯
業界裡面分析裡面
我邏輯應該是數一數二啦好不好
見底的嗎好不好
這圖好像沾染
你剛才說那個圖喔
來這看一次
來來
等一下喔
在嗎
好
沒有關係
剛才說那個堂堂檔局嘛
對 圖片
有沒有
圖片 這個有沒有
三頭有沒有
欸不是
是不是
有沒有看到 檀檬檀區
郭子龍檀檬檀區有沒有看到
有
這個有沒有
看一下
跟詹妮克有沒有差
好像他的比較粗
好啦 人家比較帥啦
我靠腦袋啦好不好
小鮮鬧
不好意思好不好
好不好
我也可以畫那麼白
車遠
這個真的跟他比真的是
坦凡坦居不自量力
賺氣度
比智商我認為不會比他低
好不好
所以扯遠了
我們比賺錢好不好
來
我們來看一下
黃友晶會撒去拉錢
真的很誇張
今天連電電來說消息
我們接下來
要满載要接近满載呀
哇
AI不是泡沫
你覺得
你看台經電那麼抗疊
你覺得聯電最後不是要跟環球機買CG
你知不知道
連那些記憶體到最後
到最後
南亞科我去年50塊的時候買我被人家罵
蛤
被罵嗎
被罵因為我給他40幾塊
是
我被罵去年的時候而已啊
我現在怎麼摺摺什麼
忘記跳舞幹嘛
你知道什麼舞嗎
不是
什麼什麼
上車舞嗎
上車舞囉
是不是什麼摺摺什麼
忘記我買什麼的
大家說
欸
提到40幾塊有沒有到44.05
欸一路拉啦
我還在跳上車舞啊
我跟你講
其實喔
股市版是專業
心理素質也是一個專業
你真的不敢相信
我跟你說真的
我對天發誓
你看我表現知道
今天我在賺錢的時候
我股票賠錢我心情超差
所以台灣股市差下去的時候我心情比較好
好不好
因為股票也跌
那我也賠錢我反而比較開心
至少
你會覺得我跟你在一起
我買一億不是要去炫富
我買一億是要讓你知道我跟你在一起
我買一億是要告訴你
我壓力也不跟你講
好不好
這不只是說我抽不出這個一億元
而是大家全部看我笑話
可是我很享受它
因為我覺得大家看我笑笑話的同時
你是有選擇的
你選擇可以相信我或不相信我
你可以選擇
要不要這個時間點買的跟我一樣漂亮
39,000點
我買之前都會預告
我買的時候當天也跟你講
買了之後有時候還比我更低
去哪邊找到這張分析師
環球競爭的你告訴我
記憶體到最後也是需要這些信心員
AI圖
你知道我做這個談談談局
你知道我誰做的
你知道這誰做的
這張圖嗎
這張圖
是
是TradeGPT做的
我去年不是說TradeGPT
在Gamer來面前TradeGPT不是垃圾嗎
對
我那時候是用這一句話來告訴你
台灣股市3萬到4萬
怎麼回事一下
因為什麼
因為ChairGPT
Gmail來進步太快了
本來ChairGPT一直贏啊
Gmail來進步很快
作圖很厲害
對
現在你看他作圖
我只講郭總的三個字喔
他生出來啊
我用Gmail來告訴郭總
他搜尋不出來我
所以我也算想當當的能有名啊
有沒有知道
這張圖歡迎截圖
喔 這樣就是筆記才對有沒有知道
他的膽君永不退縮
團結信心紀律策略勝利
啊我再想四搖
我剛才叫他比例不對嘛對不對
對
事實上再把它亮一點
有些人可能要截圖亮一點
這些字要清楚一點
再重新做
這是用ChangePT
AI一直進步啦
AI 99.99999999999999
不是泡沫
AI投資 99.99%不是泡沫
一個是AI的趨勢啦不是泡沫
一個是投資啦
有時候投資投資過頭
我不會試啦
現在股市很變態
你們有沒有想過一件事情
其實我覺得現在戳破一點點泡沫沒什麼不好
我那時候是AI有點泡沫
那不是現在對不對
現在還是
現在下去以後我覺得反好
你一下子找到10萬點台灣股市沒救啊
你聽得懂嗎
所以那時候我說你一下子含5萬點喔
我覺得有點不負責任
我強調一件事我不是針對誰喔
不然我不是針對誰喔
我沒有針對誰
我絕對不會針對誰
我還強調一件不針對誰
這是我自己的想法
可是現在我可以告訴你
我覺得今年台灣股市反而會上5萬點
為什麼
籌碼洗錢乾淨的 融資生意洗1000億的
今天還會再減少
我跟講那些融資減少的話 可能只有現金
他現金以後可能會衝
單衝會亂一點點
哇我就爛命一條我就拚了
聽著講的話
股市到時候會彈很兇
會比彈太中 李世民彈得更兇
彈太高啊
彈太遠了
好不好
彈太遠
彈很遠啦
是
飛太遠 來 看一下
這樣飛太遠
太危險
沒有危險啦
台詞
台詞好不好
好啦
再跟大家講
來來
都可以來
分析假如都可以帶會員賺錢
那為什麼要帶會員賺錢
因為就是我這樣子啊
講的什麼話
莫名其妙看著我
我4月5月的時候還說
所有會員每一支都賺錢
你們打聽一下好不好
我就講過最經典的例子
去年啦
還有
去年啦還有人說
哇組織就會
所以我心心思思跟主力配合
結果法院毫我清白
全台灣唯一法院證明的
我也不用解釋這麼多
反正先把人封鎖啦
我不需要解釋證明
為什麼
我很多股票
我不敢說現在買一定賺錢
但我很多股票你放個幾個月
甚至有時候長一點
一陣子過一兩年過
國總根本是股神啊
我的股票居然漲十倍了
我神經病我把它賣在最低點啊
好多會員是因為這樣回來的
有些會員是一參加參加好幾年
人在座天在看
第一件事 你們就問一下
我法院都已經還我證明了
我郭子龍不去跟主力配合
唯一台灣法院
唯一台灣唯一法院證教所的證明
我不跟主力掛鉤
哇靠 靠得很誇張
跑去爭取大隊啊
還有警政署的
還有人就找警政署的高層
有什麼用 我就沒做這件事情啊
我的心心裡說我120 要70塊
罵我是混蛋
從70塊找到1000塊誰是混蛋
那些說我是害你的人才是最惡劣的
你聽懂嗎
沒錯
地檢署確骨114年度他治
1233號直接簽結
能弘是非多少
什麼簽結
至少兩個警察官說我完全沒問題
證交所去對
是我任何人頭帳號都測試出來
人在做天在看
你們平常心靈好不好
台灣股市就算今天崩盤對不對
還要漲38%
所以現在已經回到一個合理的範圍內
你聽懂嗎
聽懂還說什麼嗎
是之前漲太快了 飛太遠了
我這點就是
你要拿我阿公的姓名來讀
是我阿祖也沒關係
不要拿阿祖 因為阿祖姓名我忘記了
不好意思
拿我阿公的姓名來讀一下
我告訴你5年內台國安股市又上10萬點
今年上5萬點
我很大盤你去看一下我準確率
你們不要講些是是而非
哲哲如果那麼厲害如果怎樣
你們根本就沒有每天看我節目有什麼資格講我啊
有些人就是很悲觀
賺不了錢不要怪別人賺不了錢
借這件事情
反正我告訴你6萬點我再捐一台救護車
喔 捐救護車怎麼樣怎麼樣
至少我有捐救護車
我又沒有說我一定清白
可是至少我願意回饋收費
我沒有要管住每個人走
我只能告訴你我心與你同在
我只能告訴你今天我台灣50
賺錢賺幾百萬的時候
我沒有很開心
因為我看到股票跌
最後台灣50殺下來的時候
我變得差不多不賺不賠的時候
我反而比較開心一點
因為我覺得你也可以買很低
股票你現在也可以買
我懇求你現在可以買
我如果
記得我一句話
如果今天我一億獻金
我不是分析師
今天沒有限制我買股票
我第一件事就尻下去買環球金
當然我不會all in
好不好
因為你股票還是要分散投資一下
我會買環球金
或者中美金
好不好
你去想看你要怎樣分析師啦好不好
來啦
這張圖片給你大家用
是要等一下發在那個
發在那個TG
Telegram好不好
他們下載去用
還有那個YT
我又要YouTuber
這時候有沒有到
一人第一大軍
撐住台股有沒有到
什麼
台股必勝 多頭不滅
我們一起喊口號
再一次
信心
紀律
策略
勝利
團姐你不要
這個時候你也不要
你不要在大家怪來怪去的
你怎麼好怪的啊
你只要不要融資那沒關係
信心
對我要信心
你對自己沒信心你看看我節目
很有信心很好笑
激勵
你至少現金買股嘛
就我說你這要借錢你不要借到20%嘛是不是你資產不要借到20%而且隨時有人力還你有穩定的工作所以這時候工作是很好我是叫你不要亂離職
我都跟你講過了
策略
什麼叫策略
譬如說你現在你可以先買一些股票
你不一定要買台灣50
算會比較慢
你可以買00981A
等到台灣股市要穿新高的時候
他可能賺40%
台灣50可能賺到20%
那時候再換台灣50
聽懂嗎
因為中產期還是台灣50的跡下比較好
策略我就教你了
或者現在你就是買那些疊墜生
打對疊個股龍頭股
環球金國巨閉著眼睛買
你現在閉著眼睛買
我這個名言你記不記得
我記得我記得
我記得告訴你一件
天黑請閉眼
現在不開心閉眼睛就好了
股票不要看了
真的
我這句話為什麼大家很喜歡
天黑請閉眼
天亮請儲錢
等到天亮的
股災過去了
原來賺錢那麼簡單
對啦
只要講是對的
我就這麼多粉絲就是這樣子過來的
好不好
最後怎樣
就勝利了
這在哪給你看
好不好
人家長紅
人家什麼什麼 猴
武安猴
我是晚安猴啦
我的虛虛比較細一點啦
不重要
重點是我常常展具
OK嗎
你看我叫四條都比例用
顏色清楚就差很多
AI可以用很多
啊那個
沒有那個
就是說這些是通用型的
隨時可以漲價好不好
我已經用習慣了
我現在最喜歡他
我覺得比LINE更需要
可以賺很多錢可以做很多事情好不好
你們不要想這些好不好
以後這些也可以打廣告什麼的
插個支度性廣告也可以
好不好今天外資賣40百八13億普通
來我們來看一下還是有些開始股票的跌
直跌了
5347世界監禁
要買不買不買不買
我現在就想買環球金
跌太深了你太誇張了好不好
直接跌一倍真的很誇張
我現在就想買國具
跌那麼深就買了
啊哲哲會不會到時候搶反彈
搶不到被套牢
今天去很多人搶
我會不會叫你要搶多短
你搶那麼短幹什麼
你看那麼短嗎
看一次
哲哲看起來那麼短嗎
你不要那麼短嘛
你自己要那麼短關我什麼事
哲那麼短嗎
watch me 看著我
有那麼短嗎
沒有
所以你不要搶那麼短的反彈
你不要搶那麼短的反彈
好不好
反正現金你就謝謝我
陳泰銘喔
人家高檔會賣
低檔他不會想賣的啦
神經病喔
兩三百元漲了456萬
所以現在買很大丈夫啊
你覺得陳湛明為什麼昨天法座又不出現
你們一定問他要不要賣股啊
他才不會回答我
我回答我說我不賣股
到最後我想賣怎麼辦
所以我乾脆不要出現
以上是我揣測啦
但我也知道
我認為他是在想這件事情
當然想賣但不是現在賣
他要賣我認為是1000塊
至少800元是要賣
我股票最強的
你們爸爸手一半股票
就告訴你一半股票最好一半股票選什麼
選最慘的另外一半股票選什麼
選最看跌的微星看起來就接
微星會是率先噴出去的
是
比如說我買環球金
中美金我買一半
這兩個比較像啦
這兩個母公司子公司
買環球金跌很深再買國巨一半
這抽一半的
另外買最強的 微星
有沒有知道
是不是
那另外一個可以買比較
台積電
台積電也很抗跌啊
有沒有知道
有沒有
或者世界先進
雖然跌但沒有跌的
那個
那些股票那麼兇
是不是
ok嗎
有跌一半的股票
你就買一半
有沒有知道
買一半的錢
跌一半快買一半
另外一半
買準備創新卡
他知道啊你最大問題沒有錢
沒有錢
沒有錢就每天看我節目當笑話
就這樣子而已
就這樣子
OK嗎
只得每天激動給你看
好不好
真的
別人看我太方便
我笑他人看不穿
你們一定要
你們把我指的節目當作
財經節目也好
綜藝節目也好
直銷節目也好
心理雞灘也好
你就是不能不看我節目
你不看你撐不過去
你記得這句話
我支持你
我買那一億我不是要跟你宣布
我只要告訴你我感同身受
其他人要罵那些
有些人叫 姐姐沒在賠錢
莫名其妙 是我在賠
你們照做你們都沒有賠
早就換成台灣人在做天在看
我什麼時候騙過你們
投資方面我基本上沒有騙你們
去打聽一下姐姐
好不好
這些股票這樣
簽住撐住
撐住我愛你們
這已經是股宅等級
真的
這個比去年前年還誇張
中小新過國
可是也是誇張
每次的危機照就有機會
但是你們再清楚一些事
去年而已
去年最低年什麼時候
我在跟你們提起
你們要忘記對不對
你看
好了三八 忘了痛
去年最低點
1萬8
去年到今年下就漲了一倍多
漲了3萬點
一年漲3萬點
去年危機也不是1萬8 1萬7 1萬7你知道嗎
攢3萬1千點欸
莉莉妳敢相信嗎
不敢相信啊 這麼多
你在危機的時候才能買到那種可以翻倍的大盤
跟台積電欸
去年4月11號台積電多少錢你看一下
18418嘛
台積電好慘喔
225元啦
去年什麼多少錢
那個沒有
等我一下
2025年4月9日
780元有沒有看到
天啊三倍
有沒有看到啦
放大放大
去年台積電780元
就是股災啦
我只要正問你們一件事情
拜託你們告訴我
如果股災的時候你還是看我節目
你現在愛我還是恨我
那時候我也是買台積電
台積電780元
台積電就在去年而已
就是股災 就跟現在一樣長
這是台積電我反而沒有買的價值
因為太多股票買的價值
國際要 環球金要
我問你一件事
去年股災會是買台灣股值
那時候台積電780元
去年而已
今年台積電崩盤
崩到2205元
你在說什麼話
綽綽有餘
還有
還差不多三倍
快三倍
漲了1500元
立立有講這個道理
沒錯
你看看去年的時候
你看我節目最少是什麼
我看起來算很年輕
但其實我在股市20年
我還是有一點點白頭髮
我單分一是20年
我股市30年
這個股災已經是股災
現今買年又謝謝我
AI
百年大忌啊
好不好
安妮不是忌諱的忌啊
整隻壓力太大該休息了
三升啊
我覺得我最近壓力大
今天稅比較少
大概五六個小時
我要告訴我自己盡量七個小時
可是我不會
我覺得有時候燃燒生命也沒什麼不好
偶爾燃燒啦
一年才一次而已沒關係
好不好
九千人看著折了
一萬人低點
折的資源怎麼看
資源喔
我跟你說真的喔
假設你們一些股票比如說資源就對
雖然這樣有點跌下去崩盤
資源今天不應該崩
資源是跌下去
如果資源在這邊
譬如說
我覺得資源不應該這樣跌
真的真的
我覺得整個
今天變成有些阻力已經整個崩潰了
你知道嗎
這不應該這樣
資源最好笑的是
它本來就沒什麼漲跌什麼
天啊你看這些國標
你看我真的都懶得看它
真的是
因為都跌得太誇張了
你們就撐一下好不好
撐一下相信我
好不好
晚一點點點
好像剛好人還算我
半年上5萬點
戳戳有餘啊
台灣股市一年漲3萬點
為什麼半年不能增加1萬點
台灣股市一年12個月就漲了3萬點
我剛才可以證明給你看
為什麼我短短6個月不能再漲1萬點
有道理
而且我短短一個月漲1萬點才漲25%而已
去年是1萬7 漲到4萬8
是
漲得快什麼
快200%
一個是25% 一個是200%
200%一下子都可以快過了
25%會很難
算數學也知道
好不好
不要再問群年的
群年的我看一下
不要不要不要
我還是很
只是我越看心情越不好
群年比翔中厲害耶
不錯不錯
因為群年你算一下本益比好不好
我算不下去好不好
之後都會噴出去的
再洗籌碼而已
我3月的時候我就說
記憶體會影響韓國股市
韓國股市
韓國股市崩盤運行台灣股市
我這邊不報過重播嗎
四個月前誰會跟你講這些東西
只是那時候我看太遠了
所以那時候我空手
我沒有選對時間
真是沒有
應該選到這個時間
那很難選啦
可是我跟你講最好的時機就是做多
你相信我你又謝謝我啦
我真的懇求大家好不好
我不敢說每個的還有錢
我認為100個年生是
至少20位到40位
20%到40%
你還有錢
你不想去總而已啦
你不想去湊而已
用力去湊啦
相信我買現金湊錢
去湊錢
湊了錢All in 下去
All in All in All in
只要現金你覺得就給我全壓
好不好
只是我那個明年要用錢
明年再說好不好
今年就會漲上去的好不好
可是你自己風險自負
不好意思因為我們是合法投顧
沒有百分之百
但我信心十足
我用一義來告訴大家
好不好 現在幾分了
好不好
美國夜盤崩盤的
看一下
跌410點
又破跌是不是
有美國股市跌嗎
我跟大家講好不好
你們還是買好不好
相信我隨時會噴出去好不好
像風很正常啊
好不好再洗一下而已
再洗一下
我們看一下夜盤
這夜盤有跌嗎
納斯達克變平盤了
也沒怎麼樣
現在是信心面好不好
股市人消消的
股市消消好不好
好不好
該不會外資鎖定
很多人看我的節目啊
好不好
OK
假如再跌8000點你們撐得住啊
我撐得住喔
我認為我很多會員撐得住
是
我甚至跟大家講
我跟他們講
如果再跌8000
其實我不太懂
為什麼我們要講那些最壞的情況
再跌8000點你也撐得住啊
你應該撐得住就不要看股票了
可是你知道講的
我跟你講你人生是很苦短的啊
再過100年怎麼看
死掉了啊
我的意思是說你人生為什麼要看那麼慘的事情啊
好悲哀喔
命就一條撐住就好了
我告訴你這件事
我這時候你去明言
跟有人說再疊八線怎麼辦
悲觀的人邏輯都對
樂觀的人轉走一切
這我最後送給你的話
你要悲觀的過日子
那是你的選擇
不是我選擇
不要來當我粉絲
因為你痛苦我也痛苦
好不好我是跟你說真的好不好
真的很悶搞自己很悶的
去跑跑步
去游泳游
去看看夜景好不好
運動最實在
再去重訓
運動啦
游泳運動比較容易很開心啦
重訓比較難
精彩也是這樣幾分啊
我要結束來為結束好不好
你看我今天都一些股票
精彩最可憐啦
本來要創新高跟天天跌停
咳笑咳笑
400點今天月盤跌跌就400點
我告訴你你買的比我低啊
我還巴不得你買的比我低
明天就all in
最後記得的話明天就all in
昨天沒有all in前天沒有all in
記得今天早上一大盤大早
拉出1500點以上的漲幅的時候
你是後悔你沒有all in
如果你今天大載1500點
一度大漲拉上去1500點
你後悔沒有OE
我告訴你
等到台灣股市最後漲1萬點
你還會再後悔一次
我聽我錯逼要幹嘛
你要跟我一起賺錢
才是實在
歡迎來電下群
080668085
加油來施許我
年底5萬點見
5年內10萬點見
跟我一起OE
跟我一起賺大錢
我來做你最後的後盾
我來支撐你的心
我們就命一條
我們往前衝就對了
跟我一起賺大錢
謝謝各位 掰掰
本公司与所推荐分析之个别有价证券
无不当之财务利益关系
本节目资料仅供参考
投资人应独立判断
审慎评估并自负投资风险